hello everybody I hope that you are good
this video is going to be quite
different because it's for those who
want to start to get ready for the next
Ballroom I want to start to get into
altcoins
and we're gonna discuss in this video
the possibility
real possibility in my opinion and quite
likely the Arts see new lows the title
is not clickbait in my opinion this is a
real possibility and I'm gonna explain
you why I think this can happen and at
the moment is probably the most
likeliest scenario in my opinion so
let's start with this okay we're in the
Bitcoin dominance this is basically a
chart that measures the dominance of
Bitcoin versus altcoins okay so it's
simple if the chart goes up then Bitcoin
is gonna outperform altcoins and if the
chart goes down okay then the altcoins
are going to outperform bitcoin it's as
simple as that now I have this image
here that I recommend you to to download
it you can take a screenshot or easier
you can go to Google and search Bitcoin
dominance cycle and you're gonna find
this image okay but basically it says
what I said by the more detail way
instead you hear that when Bitcoin
dominance goes up that means that
Bitcoin is outperforming altcoins okay
so the best cases scenario for altcoins
is just to be stable
but if Bitcoin increases the health
coins are gonna go down and now pay
attention to this if the Bitcoin goes
down the outcomes are going to take a
big dump
okay this basically means that if the
Bitcoin dominance is going up
okay that means the altcoins are going
to be doing bad against Bitcoin so if
Bitcoin is going down
even worse
maybe Bitcoin going down
one person or maybe the outcomes can go
down three four percent so that's
something you have to keep in mind now
in the other hand if Bitcoin dominance
is going down the altcoins are gonna be
safe okay if Bitcoin decreases the algon
is the most likely is that they are
stable and they're not either going up
or down now if Bitcoin is stable
Bitcoin
and this is the next scenario when we
can see an old season is when Bitcoin
goes up and the Bitcoin dominance goes
down why because altcoins are gonna do
better than Bitcoin and if Bitcoin is
already doing good allcons are going to
be doing even better so then you want to
have an old season
the problem that we have with this chart
is that we've been in this range for two
years okay this we started the rain
scene May 10 2021 so you know next week
it was going to be two years that's
crazy two years of sideways in a Range
so let me let me draw first the the
bottom of the range that will be around
here okay and then the top of the range
I would say that it's something like
this
okay
all of this
you can see that right now we are at
resistance okay in the previous times
when Bitcoin came to this area it went
down
well this area didn't get there really
bad or in this area went down okay so I
remember in this candle still here
Candlestick here 10th of April
I remembered I saw crypto Twitter was
calling for an old season
and I'll tell you something it's
impossible because it's simple as that
this was an internal season this was not
another season
and this wasn't an old season
these are just a small altcoins rallies
okay if we zoom out
they're gonna see that we are at the
lows
this was an old season this drop here
you can see the difference that was the
old season that we saw at the start of
2021 and lasted until May that was an
old season this over here that was an
old season
but these things here they are not all
systems they are just alt rallies that's
all they are yes you can make a lot of
money here of course I'm not gonna deny
that you can make a lot of money but
they are in all systems
okay nothing compares to what we saw at
the start of 2021 the first half of the
year was spectacular you could see your
portfolio doubling every day or every
hour even it was it was insane I
remember that but right now if you
notice what are the lows okay so if this
when we break out of this range what
direction do you think are gonna break
out to the downside or the upside
I think it's pretty clear we're gonna go
to the website okay I think it's pretty
clear and if you check
the Bitcoin dominance
cycle
when the Bitcoin dominance increases
alts are not gonna do well
okay so you have to keep diamond
so we're in a Range the windows in a
breakout sooner or later and right now
we are at resistance you can see now the
next question that we have to ask
ourselves is is this time looking any
different than the previous times
yes I think yes because if you notice
what usually happens when we get to
these highs is that we see a weak and a
strong reaction it happened here it
happened here
well this didn't get durable again a
week and price goes to the bottom of the
of the range it happened here again now
this time
is looking a bit different isn't it
because you can see this week
okay press is reacted but then comes
back up instantly
and now we have a candle close
in this song we haven't had that before
and it seems that to me that this week
what we might be saying is
a flip of resistance to support
okay so what about if we see something
like this okay
then again flip this level this higher
resistance and then price can go higher
maybe to 52 54. okay imagine if this
happened at the same time as Bitcoin
goes down and has you know some kind of
retrace because keep in mind that
between High School Loop quite quickly I
would say from 15K to 30k
that's a massive move and yes Bitcoin
has done some some important retraces
well
you know we are right now 31k well we
would have 31k now we're at
2028k what if the Bitcoin dominance goes
up
at the same time as Bitcoin say that it
goes to 25k 22k what would happen to
altcoins
well let's check the bit condominance
cycle
Bitcoin dominance goes up when Bitcoin
goes down
then we're gonna see the altcoins
decreasing fast that's gonna be a big
dump okay they're gonna go to the floor
if that is the case
if you know to me to meet a bit
condominant seems that it's quite likely
that I breaks to the upside or at least
it's looking quite strong at the moment
it's looking also different than any
time two years ago
um this is the only time that you can
see that there is a high probability
that it breaks to the upside
so that's that's all that's a start
now if Bitcoin starts to go down from
here at the same time as the Bitcoin
dominance goes up
the altcoins are gonna go to the floor
and they're probably gonna make new lows
that's my point we're not on the daily
time frame and I want to compare the
price of the Bitcoin dominance that's
the normal chart green and red candles
versus the price of Bitcoin that's the
Orange Line okay so you can see that
right now we had a
800 okay Bitcoin is going up and the 9th
of April where uh let me check 9th of
April 20 600 ish so that's you know
pretty much the same level now in the
Bitcoin dominance you can see that this
same day the 9th of April the highest
point was
47.66 percent
and now
we are a 48.5 percent so that's telling
you that the Bitcoin dominance has some
strength and this adds Confluence to the
idea that you know the possibility of
Bitcoin dominance breaking out of this
range to the upside is quite likely
what now in this chart is called total
free is this one here and it's basically
the market cap of crypto excluding
Bitcoin and ethereum so it's basically
altcoins unstable coins so we can see
how the Alphonse are doing okay this is
the weekly no the daily time frame sorry
you can see that right now we are below
the 50 EMA you know and let me tell you
as long as we are below the 50ma and we
are testing it as a resistance so many
times look at this the AMA is just gonna
push price down okay that's what's gonna
happen now this even more interested in
my opinion let's compare
the total three with Bitcoin okay
because now you can see that Bitcoin
is uh this level over here okay let me
draw a straight line
okay Bitcoin is at this level
um I mean it's difficult to tell
was that also the 9th of April yes
that's the that's the 9th of April okay
so when Bitcoin was at this level
in the past in this so here the 9th of
April so you can see that the altcoins
were in this Zone
okay now
Bitcoins at the same level as the 9th of
April
and the altcoins are in this level
okay so let me remove this now
so that's telling you
the altcoins are already starting to
feel the effect of the Bitcoin dominance
going up
okay so that's telling you that there is
a lot of weakness in the altcoins
if you have altcoins over Bitcoin right
now your portfolio you know it's not
it's you're not getting as much money
you're losing money
it's as simple as that if you have
Bitcoin it would be safer at this time
now let's go and check some altcoin
charts because we should see something
very similar
to the total three in outcomes okay
because this should be copying this this
this this this chart okay so let's check
for example Ada this is Cardinal okay
let's check but you can see that the
chart is quite similar
um yes you can see oh pacardano has gone
up and 90 has almost double price since
the lows okay now let's check
Ada versus Bitcoin numbers
what do you see here
making new lows constantly constantly
making new looks and I can tell you that
the most likely thing unus is the
Bitcoin dominance reverses here
and he goes again to the bottom of the
chart of the range
the most normal thing is that cardeno
versus Bitcoin keeps making lower loss
okay so you know let's go now to the uh
uh dot for example
let's see Dot
all right we have
quite a similar chart
let's check that's another
88 up quite similar to the total three
let's check now dot versus Bitcoin
oh what a surprise it's making new new
lows look this last week we saw new laws
constantly making new lows now imagine
if the Bitcoin dominance
keeps going up and breaks out of this
range
this is gonna blitz so badly and when
Bitcoin
goes down versus the dollar so basically
when the Bitcoin USD chart goes down
you're gonna see
this chart dot versus us
also going down very strong
so
I don't know how to tell you these guys
but I don't see
I don't see how else can be safe at this
point you know as long as the Bitcoin
dominance does
something different to what it seems
that I might be doing and it and it goes
down again to the bottom of the range
altons are not safe so in my opinion
it's not a good time to buy altcoins
let me show you an example of what
happened back in 2018 so you can see how
important is the Bitcoin dominance okay
so back in 2018 we could see that with
condominance formed a double b pattern
and then we had a trend from May 2018 to
September that's five months of uptrend
now in that time Bitcoin didn't really
do much because you can tell here that
Bitcoin has a support and it was testing
in the support you know ranging no
moving much then Bitcoin went down
okay and the the Bitcoin dominance they
then follow the Bitcoin dominance was
ranging in this Zone okay in this time
ALS o took a massive dump now if we go
for it and check the two dollar three
between November
um December I think it was that between
November December total three
we can see that I think it's in this
Zone yeah around this Zone
so this was a 60 percent down now
consider that this is also altcoins and
stable coins so it's not really sixty
percent it's more like a
65 70 percent at least I would say 65 70
is quite realistic for altcoins so damn
it was massive let's go back to the
Bitcoin dominance
okay let's see what we are today
okay let me remove all of this
I don't want this mess in my chart
so we're in this zone now imagine if the
Bitcoin dominance flips this resistance
as support okay anything is here and at
this time Bitcoin goes down
but the Bitcoin dominance is not going
down it's ranging here what do you think
would happen to altcoins
altcoins would be destroyed so in my
plan is to not buy out points here okay
if you are you know if you want to do
DCA because you've bought higher then
yes you can for example go I'm gonna see
chaining because we have Charter
changing last week so it's a very recent
chart that I have in my head this is
chain link in this Zone over here at 15
or 10 dollars then yes you can you know
you could DCA in this Zone at the at the
bottom of the range but if you haven't
bought yet
I would either Buy
at confirmation of the Breakout
okay
or
if Bitcoin dominance
goes up
then chain link is probably gonna fall
to this area all the way to four to
eight
for four dollars eighty cents
so keep that in mind because you know
that narrative I just told you I say
quite valid we only need to see the
Bitcoin dominance flipping that
resistance into support
and then
Bitcoin probably not you know a bigger
Retreat maybe to 25k 22k but obviously
the lower it goes you know the lower the
lower is gonna be the market cap
excluding Bitcoin and ethereum so the
outcomes are going to do a lot worse
you know for now I'm not expecting
Bitcoin to go you know to test the lows
or or go or go lower but
you know who knows if Bitcoin went even
lower went again to do 18K or so it's
very normal that we would see the total
market cap excluding Bitcoin and
ethereum maybe going on over here okay
because you know this is also an
imbalance and it's a chart that I can
use my trading system and chart so it
might come all the way to 200 billion
dollars market cap and that would be
huge that would basically mean that a
lot of all coins would disappear
but the thing we see die in other Cycles
why not in this cycle why is not
happening this cycle has the total free
really has the altcoins gone down
enough
I don't know you know sometimes I think
like this I remember that in previous
Cycles we saw so many Youngs disappeared
in like 90 percent of all coins
disappeared it was crazy
you know if you get a screenshot for
from coin Market from the coin market
cap
back in time and you see the top 20 best
altcoins that I've showed you now
you are not going to recognize them and
they were at the top
so Gua isn't that happening in this
cycle has the has the total three
gone down enough or does he still have
some way lower maybe to 200 billion
dollars
I don't know get this in mind guys I
would tell you that you know if you are
doing DCA
um I don't want you to after watching
this video to become greedy
um you know if you are doing DCA
it's a valid valid Zone to do DCA but if
you haven't bought any altcoins yet
I would suggest
that you buy after you see
um confirmation of the move for the
altcoins for the total three
okay or just wait because maybe you get
a cheaper opportunity a cheaper price
okay and then I can tell you this would
be
lifetime
money okay this will change your life
this money because look at this
um let me go for example to
to chain link okay
yeah I like changing let's go to chain
link
um imagine if you you know you want to
get to prepare for the next
ball Ballroom
and you buy uh
at this price now seven dollars okay
seven dollars and you want to sell let's
say
um
I don't know let's see
forty forty dollars for example
for example that's a 469 percent now if
you buy low one you buy for example a
then we are talking
about
731 you can see the difference is quite
big so I'm telling you you know if you
buy now you are the risk that maybe
outcomes can go lower and you are
missing a cheaper opportunity
okay now you might be also be missing
you know because maybe now it's the
outcomes start to go up I didn't have
some confirmation and you buy here and
yes you're gonna lose some appreciation
in price but you're gonna have
confirmation so you know it's not
Financial advice I put in a balance and
see what you think is more worth it
thank you so much for watching guys
and I'll see you soon